(soft ambient music)
- All right, it's 13 minutes.
At 15, I say we leave.
Sign in.
- Facts, facts, yeah.
- Hello, I'm sorry I'm late.
That'll never happen again.
Okay, welcome back
to another year at this
illustrious institution.
As you know, being at a
historically black college
and university is a lot like
being surrounded by family.
So I should say welcome home.
Let's get started with roll, shall we?
Simone Fisk?
- From Nashville, Tennessee,
music management major.
(ding)
By the way, $30 bottles, XXX, anyone?
Ladies free until 11, but you know,
doors open at 12.
- Alright, that's enough.
Do we have Janette Spellmen here?
- I'm from Atlanta, Georgia.
(ding)
I know some of you may not recognize me,
but over the break I
decided to cut my hair.
So now, you know, I'm team natural.
- Oh, my God, I love your texture.
What do you put in it?
- Girl, I use a growth oil,
coconut styler,
and I use a blueberry pomade for my edges.
- Marcus Gramley?
Okay.
No Marcus.
(ding)
Welcome to class.
You're late, what's your name?
- Meckenzie Howard, but I go by Mecka.
- Could you give us your into.
- I'm a fashion major
with a minor in marketing.
(ding)
And I'm from DC.
Oh, and something about me...
Oh, I modeled in New York
Fashion Week recently.
- Okay, Mecka, please put your phone away.
Who do we have next?
We have a Michael Dillard?
- My name is Michael X,
Dillard is my slave name.
(ding)
- X is a good, strong last name.
Just spelled "X?"
Just "X," "EX," or...?
X, okay, cool, great.
And who do we have?
Oh, Mr. Cookman, welcome back.
Good to see you again.
We're gonna get through it this time.
- Hey, Professor Hamsen.
(ding)
- Alright, so as you
know, the syllabus reads
that we start at Chapter 11,
'cause I know everybody got
the syllabus and read it.
(ding)
So, what's gonna happen is,
we're gonna have a test every week,
a paper every week,
keep those skills sharp.
Let's begin, any questions?
Good, I don't like questions.
Let's go.
(soft ambient music)